wir schauen auf diesen dürre sommer 2022
der liegt in den flüssen alles frei was
sonst dort in der tiefe verborgen ist
diesen hunger felsen in tschechien der
steht dort seit dem 17 jahrhundert und
darauf steht wenn du das lesen kannst
dann weine dort eingeritzt in diesem
felsen ja das heißt wenn dieser hunger
felsen in der elbe nicht von wasser
bedeckt ist dann ist die lage dramatisch
das hat man sich also damals schon
ausgedacht dramatische dürre bei uns
jetzt bild reporter jörg völkerling
genau dort ich grüße dich herzlich du
bist 70 kilometer etwa südlich von
dresden auf der tschechischen seite also
dort wo die elbe labe heißt wie viel von
dieser elbe oder lage gibt es im moment
noch ein bisschen was sehe ich noch
ja es trügt ein bisschen das bild die
binnenschifffahrt die hat schon große
probleme die braucht mindestens einen
pegelstand von 1 meter dreißig wir sind
jetzt
knapp teilweise letzten tage schon in
diesem bereich gewesen wo das
eingestellt werden musste und alle
gucken an diesem historischen tag
händeringend nach oben ob es endlich
wieder regen gibt es soll heute gewitter
geben es könnte eine gewisse
wahrscheinlichkeit geben dass es heute
etwas regnet und es ist ja ein wirklich
historischer tag an dem wir heute hier
in decin stehen wir sehen hinter uns
dieser hunger stein der quasi bis in das
15 jahrhundert zurückgeht da gibt es die
ersten in schriften liegt frei und er
lag nicht frei vor 20 jahren am 15
august als hier das elbe-hochwasser
sozusagen seinen höhepunkt erreichte als
dresden geflutet wurde 21 menschen
verloren damals ihr leben man kann sich
das kaum vorstellen damals war der elbe
höchststand 12 meter und wir sind jetzt
hier bei 1 meter vierzig ungefähr der
hunger stein liegt gänzlich frei wenn
die elbe einen pegelstand von ein meter
hat es ist nicht ausgeschlossen dass das
diesen sommer noch passieren könnte es
ist wirklich ein historischer sommer
diese lange hitzeperiode das lässt sich
wirklich
seit beginn der wetteraufzeichnungen
kaum zurück verfolgen und die menschen
damals die dieser tradition der hunger
steine begründet haben hatten einfach
damit ihre nieren ihre angst vor der
apokalypse zum ausdruck gebracht dass
die schiffe sozusagen die häfen nicht
mehr erreichen können dass keine
lebensmittel mehr geliefert werden
können und so weit entfernt von so einer
situation sind wir an diesen monaten
nicht gewesen wenn wir an die ukraine
denken an die weizen lieferungen die
dann nicht rausgehen konnten aus den
helfen also diese gefahr einer
hungersnot die ist zwar noch nicht so
letztlich am himmel aber wir sehen
natürlich dass sich die anzeichen für
die klimawende hier absolut verdichten
ja das ist ja schon angesprochen also
jetzt war man ja lange jahre oder
jahrzehnte in deutschland solch einen
heißen sommer und diese theorie gar
nicht gewohnt das heißt man hat
eigentlich keine entsprechenden
maßnahmen muss jetzt aber reagieren also
was ist geplant wenn man sich auf dieses
wetter szenario ab jetzt auch für die
zukunft einstellen muss
na gut sachsen hat jetzt was hochwasser
angeht viele maßnahmen geschaffen in den
letzten jahren
spundwände eingezogen mobile da gibt es
viele maßnahmen aber wie man sich gegen
niedrigwasser wappnen will ist glaube
ich recht schwierig es gibt in
frankreich schon die ersten
atomkraftwerke die runtergefahren werden
müssen weil sie nicht mehr gekühlt
werden können weil das wasser zu warm
ist es gibt in am rhein gibt es
kraftwerke die nicht mehr mit kohle
beliefert werden können weil eben die
schiffe nicht mehr durchkommen hier an
der elbe es sieht noch relativ normal
aus aber letztlich wie man hier wirklich
abhilfe schaffen will wenn die elbe auf
unter 1 meter sinkt das ist kaum zu
sagen im moment also der hunger felsen
bei dir ist freigelegt und die elbe die
dort aber heißt hat natürlich nicht nur
hunger sondern vor allen dingen ist wann
wird dieser durst gestillt jörg
völkerling unser bild reporter also
siehst du wenn du gerne himmel chance
darauf die vorhersagen für die nächsten
tage richtig regen
naja das hat manches mal dresden auch
schon gerettet mit seiner weißen flotte
meter dampfschifffahrt das von
tschechien die wehre geöffnet worden
sind und der pegelstand der elbe sich
wieder erhöht hat
aber die letzten wochen das waren
wirklich nur tropfen auf dem heißen
stein es ist für heute tatsächlich mit
70 prozentiger wahrscheinlichkeit sind
gewitter angesagt noch mal bis zu 30
grad aber morgen schon wieder haben wir
relativ normalen sonnenschein wieder
hitze bis 34 grad am mittwoch also wann
das mal endet die einzige hoffnungsvolle
perspektive kann man eigentlich sagen
diese jahreszahlen in dem hunger stein
hinter mir zeigen hitzeperioden dürre
niedrigwasser hat das über die
jahrhunderte immer wieder gegeben das
ist vielleicht das einzig tröstliche an
diesem morgen danke an unsere bild
reporter jörg völkerling und mit dem
blick auf die nächsten tage und den
himmel wollen wir karsten brandt und
sein bild wetterexperten dazu holen denn
wir lagen uns natürlich nicht nur für
dresden wie es aussieht in den nächsten
stunden und tagen sondern für ganz
deutschland also blick nach oben karsten
brandt war noch rechnet ich stehe
draußen und ich sehe viele wolken über
mir und hier in nrw ich bin gerade in
bonn ein paar schauer schon unterwegs
ein paar regentropfen und das ist
wirklich ein jubeltag heute das muss man
einfach so sagen ein paar regentropfen
da nach langer langer trockenzeit erste
schauer unterwegs die werden jetzt nicht
die die dürre sofort beenden also dass
das wird nicht funktionieren aber sie
bringen das waldbrandrisiko runter und
das nicht nur in nordrhein westfalen
sondern sachsen haben das eben schon
gehört heute am nachmittag einzelne
schauer und gewitter elbe raum hamburger
raum auch da schauer und gewitter
schleswig-holstein einzelne schauer und
gewitter niedersachsen in bayern sehe
ich dass er aktuell auf dem radar auch
da ein paar schauer so also nicht ende
der dürre nicht der große regen aber
immerhin immerhin geht das waldbrand
dieses flächenbrand feldbrand risiko
jetzt etwas runter mit dieser feuchten
luft und ich denke das ist eine gute
eine gute nachricht erst mal definitiv
darüber wird sich die natur auf jeden
fall freuen carsten wie viele regentage
hätte es wenn im juli und august geben
müssen und wie viele gab es denn
tatsächlich
schaut mal ich habe hier den den
regenmesser hier meiner wetterstationen
der ist schon richtig schmutzig weil der
einfach nichts zu tun hatte über wochen
hinweg also es ist so dass man davon
ausgehen musste dass man 20 30 regentage
mehr im ju die und august alleine in
deutschland hätte haben müssen also da
fehlt fehlt einiges und wir haben meine
ich jetzt nicht so ein platzregen wie
wir im jahr immer häufiger haben so ein
gewitter was dann überflutungen oder so
bringt sondern eher so ein langsamer
leichter landregen dem brauchen wir
eigentlich und die ist immer noch nicht
in sicht und deswegen so ein bisschen
die vorwarnung dass der schlechte teil
der nachricht heute dass wir mit den
pegelständen an der elbe an der weser
und rhein noch lange kämpfen müssen ich
befürchte dass wir da historische
tiefstände sehen werden noch dann wenn
man es gar nicht erwartet im oktober
november hinein dies ist meist so dass
gerade dann im herbst dann die
pegelstände richtig runter gehen und
dann also die schiff hat noch probleme
hat wenn eigentlich die hitzewelle schon
längst durch ist also das wird noch ein
thema für die nächsten wochen weil
einfach die wetterlage nicht sich so
schnell ändert und so viel regen kann da
gar nicht nach fallen kann schnell noch
binnenschiffer die nicht mehr
funktioniert feuerwehrmänner die
natürlich rund um die uhr im einsatz
sind dabei den wald und feld bränden
aber sonst ja ich muss meine
balkonkästen häufiger wässern und so
weiter aber viele deutsche fragen sich
die sich auch im moment noch über die
viele sonne freuen was ist daran so
schlimm für mein leben also wie
beeinflusst die dürre den ganz normalen
deutschen naja also man merkt dass er
zum beispiel heute wenn man zur arbeit
geben muss man hat hier die nacht
schlecht geschlafen 22 bis 24 grad nach
temperatur in vielen städten man kommt
um ausgeruht dann auf die arbeit und
also das ist so ein direkter faktor den
man merkt man man schläft nachts nicht
mehr so gut und ist dann tagsüber nicht
mehr so fit also wir merken alle hier in
deutschland glaube ich diese diese hitze
im urlaub im süden ist das kein problem
aber wenn man hier arbeiten muss ist es
sehr sehr schwierig und denk mal dran
wenn das jetzt so weitergeht wenn die
temperaturen ansteigen wenn wir später
dann 43 45 grad und noch mehr wärme
gerade in deutschland haben dann wird
das unerträglich und ich denke das gilt
es zu verhindern und ich möchte euch zum
abschluss einen gewinner zeigen aus
meinem garten aus meinem comeback von
marco aufmachte großraum ich bin mal
sehr gespannt ich bin mal sehr gespannt
wie wie der wein dieses jahr wird es
muss doch eigentlich ein extrem guter
weise also meine sind komme ich
probier's jetzt einmal
[Musik]